[Music]
water Claudia DC has improved
significantly so when I grew up here a
very long time ago and when I was a
child if you went swimming and you
couldn't go swimming in the Potomac
River if you went on a boat in the
Potomac River and fell in you might be
sick for a very long time
[Music]
national triathlon includes swimming in
the Potomac which would have been
unthinkable you say 15 years ago and
it's been cleaned up in part as a
consequence
Water Act the general way that it works
is the federal government sets what are
called discharge standards you know if
you're gonna discharge a certain
pollutants into the water it can't be it
you have to use this kind of equipment
or meet the standards of this kind of
equipment t seawater has is in the
process of cleaning up some of the
sewage that goes into the Potomac the
1960s the most dominant feature was
really gross sewage the other thing I
should say is one of the very big
sources of pollution and River is human
waste I mean in others you know we you
go to the bathroom and that has to go
someplace and the that basically is
sewage and it goes through the blue
plain sewage treatment plant which has a
uses bacteria to treat it so that when
it goes into the river it doesn't just
go as when you went to the bathroom it
goes is much more treated and therefore
much less polluting starting in the late
60s early 70s there was a really
tremendous investment in
sewage improving sewage treatment that
has resulted in dramatic improvement in
water quality in the Potomac River and
the Anacostia such that today there's a
thriving recreational commercial fishery
when I was a child if you would you
would never want to fall off a boat into
the Potomac the fish wouldn't either you
can find fish in the Potomac now it's
certainly coming back it's not all there
but it's improved the Anacostia River is
a small River
to understand what's gone out of the
Anacostia you have to understand that
it's a very urbanized river and to think
about that you probably need to think
about the concept of the watershed some
Americans know what a watershed is a lot
of them dolt
in fact when you do polling on this some
people say a lot of shed as a shed where
you keep water and that's not it at all
so the watershed is the basin the drains
to a particular place if you think about
let's just say a bathtub
it was drained in the bottom of bathtub
water throughout the bathtub drains down
to that drain well that's sort of like
Watership is that the bathtub is the
watershed and it all drains to a
particular place and that particular
place is a river
[Music]
each vacation refers to the process
excessive roof
plants the consequences of that are that
when those plants that die in the
process of decaying they consume oxygen
and then when they consume all the
oxygen than the higher-level organisms
fish die
president Trump's proposed budget could
slash state grants aimed at enforcing
environmental laws as well as regional
programs that address specific pollution
problems a double whammy for some states
right now a lot of people have feared
that President Trump is gonna do what he
said he was gonna do in his campaign and
really gut the Environmental Protection
Agency and as I'm talking to you today
there's actually a freeze on all grants
and contracts from the Environmental
Protection Agency that help us to clean
our water help us to clean our air help
us to make our environment great and if
the freeze continues so that the EPA
can't help the states can't help the
cities can't help nonprofit
organizations can't help all of us that
are interested in cleaning the
environment and keeping a clean
environment then our quality of life is
going to go down a great deal whoever
the president is the American public is
pretty clear they want clean air and
clean water and clean land and we're all
going to have to keep paying attention
and keep working I have been saying I
think it is harder to unravel the
environmental protections we put in
place then some people think but I'm
worried and I think that young people
like you really have to pay attention
and really you're gonna have to make
clear that you do not want to inherit a
country where the years suddenly made
dirty again and that whoever the
president is it is very important that
we continue to implement these laws that
require that people not make more
pollution in the air
or watering again I mean that the anyone
who characterizes that important
environmental protections for cleaning
the air and water as quote job-killing
don't know what they're talking about
I'm thrilled that you asked me to talk
about this because it is really
important for young people to understand
what's going on with clean water and
let's go on out of the clean air what's
going on with the credible loss of
biodiversity of the world we have so
much noise in our society right now that
it's really hard to stay focused on
anything but if there's anything that's
important in our world it's to protect
the environment and restore the
degradation that's already and I'm just
really happy that you guys are
interested in this and I'm hoping that
anybody who sees this will learn more
about the environment and then
ultimately act both in their personal
life and in your political life to make
sure that the environment is preserved
and maintained and enhanced for
everybody's benefit the one final remark
I have is what I've always said is you
can't clean up a river by yourself you
can't clean up the air by yourself if
ever there's something that we all have
to do together collectively it is paying
attention to our environment and
improving our environment and it is a
very good ground on which we can all
stand together to take good action
you